c'est le grand retour de marcel amont
après 23 ans d'absence il vient de
sortir un disque très jazzy décalage
horaire en duos notamment avec des
artistes d'aujourd'hui
il était hier soir à l'olympia pour un
récital unique michel vial et
jean-bernard hier soir et ce pour quoi
on respecte internet et je perds et tout
avait même le maquillage et on vend
notre rythme j'ai mordu la pièce
vivement un demi siècle plus tard c'est
bien 56 vous faites le calcul
et c'est à la fois émouvant et ça fout
la trouille
ça fout la trouille lumineux vous êtes
un vieux cheval de retour aux alpes
était oui peut-être mais
et miroirs ému en effet marcel amont de
se retrouver hier soir sur la scène de
l'olympia une scène où il a très vite
repris ses marques et pour cause il y a
même chanté cette semaine d'affilée en
1970 malgré les inévitables aléas d'une
carrière au long cours commencé au
milieu des années 50
le béarnais n'a en fait jamais cessé de
chanter
gérard darmon mais aussi agnès jaoui et
maxime le forestier qui chante en duo
avec lui ont été séduits par le métier
de l'artiste une nature de comédiens
adapté à la chanson dans la tradition
intemporel du music hall puis à spin
jusqu'au cou mais sécu
au fond c'est has been n'est pas ringard
un jeu dit toujours ça un regard c'est
un mauvais qui joue les bons aline c'est
quelqu'un qui est plus à la mode saas
jules non seulement elle accepte mais je
le revendique mon coeur posé sur le
coeur de plomb de dans mon coeur je
viens d'entendre un sucre puis chanter
du cno où il chantait du du sartre ça
m'aurait pas effleuré en 1915 qui arrive
à paris en 1950 c'était l'ombre déjà
démodé un excipient basané démodé
peut-être mais toujours là avec ses
refrains populaires sa fantaisie
légendaire et une touche nouvelle de
rythmes jazzy peut-être le nouvel
épisode d'un parcours où décidément rien
n'est jamais acquis ni perdu
et pas mal monté